[Music]
[Applause]
I can feel back about coming out that is
mental
[Music]
today I'm in Worcester to meet a real
build run racer Matt Evans is one of the
top five drawn races in the country
noise Spurs on - I like GTR Hey Oh Matt
right yeah yeah yeah clap cheese man I
just know I'm gonna need that back okay
yeah nice Spanish - so this is it yeah
whoa
so this is where the magician efforts my
you've got a double bed yeah sweet Oh
God oh yeah look at that drone central
that is brilliant so where did your
passion for all things strong come from
um sir started racing cars when I was
younger I got a bit bored of the 2d on
the floor aspect so moved two planes and
stuff so flying planes how did that like
evolve into light you know using drums
we actually just came across some videos
on YouTube so we built our own and just
started flying around in a field people
started seeing that we can use trees and
other obstacles to fly around mmm so we
start to do races and realize actually
you know you can you can no money from
this companies are starting to actually
sponsor pilots so you can get salaries
just to race or if you go to a really
big event you can win 250,000 pounds
that sounds exciting I like it I like it
so these these the ones that you fly or
are they Evie's in my Racing quads so
I've got three identical ones we're
gonna fly it to those I'm actually going
to race today
so yeah tag along
[Music]
[Applause]
lovely car is this the place
yeah this is a theory yes Oh bassy this
is gonna be sweet wall its place she's
unreal massive isn't yeah yeah yeah
state of the art of it sounds to me
meant this is the boss
very good said yes so you run this gaff
yeah yeah and this is the first in the
country is it not first in the waters
far as I'm concerned it's a permanent
site yeah well that's amazing record to
hold that's a proper records
how many flips can you do it once Oh
shouldn't have said all right we'll just
go here yeah that yeah like Cyclops a
seven is that good frequency to be
flying on it to be honest L it doesn't
matter we move over to the arena kando
yeah yeah that's amazing I think I might
have just changed the frequency by
accident so can you see everything yes
yes yes are you ready yeah yeah okay oh
god no no no no no no who is sick
already that's ridiculous
I can feel like about coming out that
his mid to late winter we could do some
flips as well if you want don't do that
anymore that's crazy
[Music]
haha yes it's right
[Applause]
[Music]
want to pay for that that's mental I
think we could despite crashing we've
got no damage at least so the man of the
hour
so how was that oh that was sick so
where do you see the future of drone
racing television channels started to
take it on and big big competitions are
happening so who knows I mean formerly
one maybe you know that sort of level
definitely yes exciting times yeah sure
can I have what it takes to be a drone
right why not
anyone can really it's just practice
yeah just gotta get used to them fees
yeah well anyway I wish you all the best
of luck I think it was very good and
don't forget me when you become the
Martin shoemaker of drives I still feel
sick although drone racing seriously
blown my socks off with no idea that you
can fly a drone while sitting on a sofa
you know I mean the idea that that's an
actual job Oh
anyway yeah I better get off later yeah
because max giving me a lift oh all
right so submit it's okay all right all
right so still work get that lift your
haircut yeah yeah um do you mind if I
crash on your sofa tonight
oh that's what is it liver lever set
here